my identity has always been a rule
follower and now with edith i feel like
we're
breaking every rule
[Music]
people think of jewish food either as
israeli or middle eastern food or the
classic jewish deli
and there's kind of this big space in
between the two where a lot gets lost
there were jewish people that lived in
morocco and mexico so naturally when
people go to different regions or
different places they'll pick up
different techniques and products and
cultures and ingredients and it's kind
of like this amazing blend
being born out of displacement led to
all these different cultural experiences
and that's where edith comes into play
you really try to explore where these
untold stories come from and try to tell
them in a really approachable way
through our food just like they say
they're going to go out for thai food or
chinese food or indian food or mexican
food my goal is with edis is for people
to be like i'm going to go out for
jewish food tonight
my name's alyssa and i'm the founder of
edith's in brooklyn
we're sitting in our little teeny tiny
sandwich shop that we just opened this
past march
everybody knows a sandwich it's just
about how playful how creative we can
get with it while being true to like the
region we have a sandwich that's called
the maghreb which is focused on the
maghreb region of like northern africa
we have another sandwich called the
alhira made with a harissa mayo and like
this portuguese style chicken sausage
when the spanish inquisition was
happening and jews were like forced out
of spain they fled to portugal
jewish butchers never butchered pork
because
it's not kosher and a lot of sausage
especially in that region is all pork
based
so to help jewish people hide especially
as butchers they taught them how to make
an al hira style sausage but with
chicken or like meat that is kosher and
when i found that out i was like this is
an amazing story that we can kind of
tell through food
[Music]
the bagel here
is hand twisted because as far as we can
trace history back that was kind of like
the original bagel from krakow in poland
so i thought the twisting would actually
be a more interesting way to eat the
bagel when you twist it you get these
nooks and crannies and you get some
parts of the bagel that are a little bit
like baked more
some that are a little softer
i didn't realize how hard it would be to
sell a non-new york style bagel
in new york people have a very certain
idea what they're looking for when they
order a bagel and doing something
different than that has been
really
empowering there can be more
interpretations of a bagel and part of
a bagel is that it is boiled the reason
for boiling bagels came from the fact
that jews they weren't allowed to bake
bread so they boiled it there is an
element of creativity and there is an
element of history and storytelling and
trying to keep something true to where
it came from
it was this really serendipitous story
of how it all began but we opened our
pop-up just over a year ago
i had started talking about edith's and
i had already known that i wanted to
name it edith because edith was she's my
great aunt but she was the one person in
my life who i like really had a very
special connection with
i talked to my cousin edith's daughter
i'm
gonna do this pop-up i'm gonna call it
edith here she goes you know my mom
owned a deli and i was like what i had
no idea that she actually did own a deli
and that i
70 or 80 years later was starting this
jewish deli inspired pop-up and wanted
to name it edith
i had to find a place to actually make
everything that's not my apartment and i
emailed 15 pizzerias knowing that they
were mostly closed during the day and i
needed an oven
nobody got back to me except for paulie
and paulie emailed me back right away i
was like oh my god paulie g got back to
me i was like that's amazing i had eaten
his pizza for years i go down to 60
greenpoint and he's sitting in his big
lounge chair
you're technically our first investor i
know what i had here we weren't using it
and i like to help people get off the
ground and i love the idea just because
i'm half jewish
what i found interesting is that it's my
heritage i embrace the opportunity you
know have us serve that food here
because it was part of my heritage
cook what you love
don't come up with something that you
don't like just because you think
somebody else will buy it make that food
an extension of you
and
people embrace it
[Music]
moved to new york fresh-faced didn't
know anybody was like ready to come to
work and learn but the things that
comforted me the little pieces of jewish
food that i grew up with i couldn't
afford to eat them here they're just
really expensive and that's kind of when
i started exploring
like all these other parts of jewish
food
oh okay
oh yeah
brighton beach is one of my most
favorite parts of brooklyn it's where
a lot of russian immigrants live i like
make time to do it because i love being
around here and like exploring there's
smells there's sounds there's things
that are new and you go and english is
not a first language for a lot of people
you can kind of communicate again
through food because it's something that
everybody can understand
little speaking
russian
[Music]
it's kind of like cottage cheese yeah
it's like cottage cheese
i didn't grow up eating cottage cheese
so i couldn't really tell you christina
was like our first chef she is half
japanese and we've initially bonded over
like our mutual love of fish
we're like oh
like japanese people eat a ton of fish
jewish people like love a ton like it's
just you realize how
similar everybody is
this is what makes edith special it's
because everybody brings their own
background their own inspiration and
like these harmonious blends of
tradition and cultures and
exploration kind of just like tie
together
ben
he's one of the life bloods of our team
he
comes up with
so many dishes on our menu this is a
dish we've been working on as a team our
take on a traditional like herring and
cream we wanted to take some of those
old world comforting heavier but like
institutional jewish dishes and make
them a little bit easier for people to
digest when i first was given this dish
i had no idea what it was
so i literally did a quick google search
working with christina and ben we have
become so close as like a little family
but also creatively because we've been
able to like use
each other's cultures to like push this
menu forward and like make it what it is
today
this is our take on a traditional like
russian pancake these are all cheeses
from
the russian supermarket the bazaar
we wanted to kind of explore which
cheese would give us like the best final
product i try to keep it wholly unique
and i think what's worked well for us
and like what is
our edith's kind of like ethos is like
going so far backwards in history that
we can make things relevant again
so go to like the depths of the internet
and order crazy
books so we've been testing out
different batters different cheeses
different hydrations textures and
flavors
after that point if i really need like a
serious dose of inspiration or just like
a break i'm always just on my bike i
ride all over brooklyn and i'll eat i'll
sit i'll walk through aisles of like
specialty stores bakeries i'll hear
people speaking
russian and polish i just need to go and
like immerse myself in the cultures that
i'm really taking inspiration from
i'll live in picklebar
here
all like our bakery items will be here
we're opening a second location which is
really the true
realization i think of my dream which is
an all-day eatery and grocery store i
call it a mini
jewish italy but it's really much more
than that a place where people can
explore jewish food from all over the
world in one place through groceries
through
food through
music
we want to create something that's long
lasting like other iconic new york
institutions like the barney green grass
or the russ and daughters that's what we
have to build this with the mindset of
is like staying relevant and putting in
the infrastructure to make sure we can
be here for the next 10 years
jewish food actually didn't have a ton
of real meaning for me my whole life
until now when i started edits and i
start looking back and trying to learn
more about our food and where it comes
from and what it's born out of
and i think that that is the most
beautiful part of it is that
because it's so global in nature and
because the diaspora is so
wide-ranging across multiple countries
and continents and
all of the food cultures that are very
much the same
you see how similar everybody is and
when you encompass a lot of the diaspora
all in one place
you really can see all those
similarities and it just really
brings people together
[Music]
i like it down here
it makes me like just feel good i guess
i feel like i'm on a break from my life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you